well certainly I think along the back
moot's line of contact it stretches for
absolutely miles they are buoyed by the
successes they are limited successes we
should stress over recent days but the
fighting around back moot has been
really the most ferocious of this war
back moves itself is really a symbol for
the the horror of this conflict but the
fact that they have had success there
Has Lifted morale it's lifted Spirits
because they think they can have
breakthroughs elsewhere they're also
buoyed by the fact that they have
Western weapons coming into the country
many of the troops are returning after
being trained by Western Powers as well
so they think they can do it and this is
important the fact that they have been
able to move forwards here after months
of setbacks but they do also warn that
this counter-offensive it's not going to
be a Magic Bullet that you're unlikely
to see a full collapse of the Russian
military there's no sense really that
Vladimir Putin wants to end this war and
Russia has huge reserves of materiel and
troops so they do say that even if it is
successful this walk could still
continue not just for many months but
many years
Alex many thanks Alex Rossi there in
Ukraine